[MUSIC PLAYING]
APARNA SINHA: I'm Aparna Sinha,
product manager for Kubernetes
and Google Container Engine.
There has been a dramatic
shift in the last couple
of years in the
ability for enterprises
to realize the
speed, efficiency,
and scale benefits of
distributed computing,
whether it is in the form of
a private cloud on premise
or public clouds at
the scale of Google.
container-packaged
apps are legitimately
portable and fast to deploy
because the packaging
format provides independence
from the underlying host file
system and OS distribution.
So you can deploy an app
quickly and take it anywhere.
But containers are only
part of the solution.
Running applications in a
sea of distributed resources
poses new challenges.
For example, how do
you schedule containers
to utilize the underlying
resources efficiently when
those resources are unreliable?
How do you automatically
monitor and recover
containers and applications
when they fail?
How do you add and
remove containers
to scale the
application with demand?
And with everything
moving around,
how do clients discover
containerized applications?
Google open sourced Kubernetes
to provide a solution
for these and other distributed
computing challenges
based on over 12 years
of experience internally.
Out of the box, Kubernetes
automates container scheduling,
health checking and recovery,
replication to ensure up time,
and internal network management
to ensure service naming,
discovery, and load balancing.
The basic concepts
Kubernetes uses
to manage container clusters
include a pod, which
is a group of containers that
are always scheduled together
and have a shared networking
and storage identity.
Pods typically bundle an app
with its helper functions,
for example, a web
server and a file puller.
A controller,
which is a feedback
loop that drives current
state towards desired state.
This is the basis for automation
at many levels in Kubernetes.
For example,
replication controllers
ensure service
continuity by making
sure a sufficient number of
pods are running at all times.
Controllers are also
used for auto-scaling.
A service is an abstraction
across pods that together
represent an application.
A service has a stable IP
address for the external world,
thereby hiding the complexity
of dynamically scheduled pods
across a cluster.
Services enable application
discovery, networking,
and load balancing.
Lastly, labels are
user-defined metadata
that can be attached to
any object in Kubernetes.
Selectors can then be used
to query the object's state
and define policies.
This enables many different
types of management operations,
for example, automated Canary
deployments or rolling updates
to name just two.
Our goal with Kubernetes is to
meet customers where they are.
Containers help you
deploy to any cloud.
Kubernetes gives you a
management stack that
can go anywhere containers can.
The freedom to deploy
on premise, in hybrid,
or multi-cloud
environments lets customers
choose based on the merits
of the underlying cloud.
Google Container Engine
provides the performance, scale,
and efficiency of the
Google Cloud platform
to Kubernetes customers.
It is one of the
easiest, fastest,
and most cost effective ways to
manage containers in production
today.
This is why thousands
of customers
run their production
environments
with Google Container Engine.
Now I would like to invite one
of those customers, Tyler Davis
from porch.com to talk about
how Google Container Engine has
impacted their business.
TYLER DAVIS: I'm Tyler Davis,
DevOps engineer with porch.com.
Porch has collected a
massive amount of data
to provide transparency
to the home improvement
industry on who is the
best professional to hire.
With terabytes of data from
both private and public sources,
Porch is able to
connect homeowners
to the highest
quality professionals
through the Porch platform.
The Porch platform is present
in over 1,700 Lowes stores
and available via the Porch
retail solution on websites
like wayfair.com
and atgstores.com.
For Porch, our
engineering objectives
start with stability
and reliability.
Website up time and
reliability are paramount.
No website means no customers,
which means no revenue.
Similarly, developer
time is at a premium.
Kubernetes ease of deployment
accelerates everything.
Kubernetes reduces
the time and overhead
for developers during new
service bootstrapping,
rolling out bug fixes
and new features,
and reduces maintenance time.
With Kubernetes, we fail
fast, but we fix it faster.
Before December 2014, Porch
had a monolithic service
architecture.
As this crude diagram
shows, we provisioned
bare virtual machines running
specific applications, often
with less than 10% utilization
due to over provisioning
for unexpected demand.
Also, there were load balancers
for each application creating
multiple layers
of load balancers,
confusing troubleshooting
of network or code problems.
Deployments could take one
to two hours on average,
sometimes half a day or
longer, with inconsistent state
for the duration of the rollout.
This was an inefficient
and ultimately expensive
implementation.
Under our new architecture,
client connections
route through a
single Google load
balancer directly into
the Kubernetes cluster.
There's only one load
balancer instead of up to four
due to Kubernetes ability to
proxy traffic between services
internally.
This actually helped us discover
bugs in our own applications
which were masked by the layers
of load balancers before.
We currently run over
100 different services
in the cluster.
These applications
are mostly stateless,
synchronizing between
other services,
and storing state on
databases or Memcache
outside the cluster.
The large multi-terabyte
databases,
configuration management
systems like Chef,
and other strictly
stateful systems
exist outside the cluster
on compute engine VMs.
Redis and other
stateful services
are being migrated
into the cluster
as we get more comfortable
with GKE features.
As a result, Porch enjoys
the following architecture
benefits-- developer
independence
as self-service architecture
allows developers
to go for commit to
deployed in production
in less than 10 minutes
without DevOps' involvement.
Deployments are reliable and
can be rolled out or rolled back
in three minutes or less.
Due to the independent
promotion architecture,
we can and do deploy as
many as 30 to 50 times a day
or more with almost no
risk and no downtime.
Finally, Kubernetes allows
us to sleep through events
that would otherwise
require a 2:00 AM conference
call in engineering.
Having worked with Kubernetes
for over a year in production,
we've learned a few things.
Create deployment
containers which
only include the minimum
necessary artifacts
and run time.
This will lead to faster
deployments and easier
reasoning about deployment
or application failures.
Also, don't expect
Kubernetes to be anything
like what has come before.
Treat your applications
like cattle.
Design for failures and
redundancy in the app.
And leverage all the
Kubernetes features available,
such as service discovery,
deployments, and health checks.
When in doubt, experiment.
Thank you for joining us.
I hope these tips can help you
to quickly and reliably scale
your own architecture.
To learn more,
visit kubernetes.io.
[MUSIC PLAYING]